another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation no unsupervised  access to scp-387  scp-387 or the living lego is a  miraculous find it is a tub of seemingly  ordinary lego bricks that when built  into a shape by human hands comes to  life and even develops sentience of  course dr bright can never let a cool  thing just exist without wrecking some  havoc with it and decided to build a  tiny lifelike model of scp-682  we have no idea how we built it so fast  or why it took military-grade explosives  to blow apart the creature made from  plastic blocks but it was a mess to  clean up and agent johnson will never  get his big toe back if dr bright is so  desperate to play with legos he'll just  have to stick to the non-magic kind